la violente tempête qui a soufflé la
nuit dernière sur l'ouest du pays a donc
entraîné le naufrage d'un pétrolier à 50
km environ au large de lorient
le tanker battant pavillon maltais s'est
coupé en deux toute la matinée les
sauveteurs ont hélitreuillé l'équipage
les 26 marins indiens ont pu être
récupérés sains et saufs
pierre didier cassé en deux mais pas
tout à fait couler l'arrière du bateau
avec ses superstructures surnage ainsi
depuis ce matin quant à la partie avant
du pétrolier elle est pratiquement
totalement immergé seule la proue pointe
encore dans une mer agitée de creux de 6
mètres
lorsque les premiers secours des
hélicoptères français mais aussi
britanniques survolent la zone du
naufrage
une partie de l'équipage est toujours
d'abord ils seront rapidement
hélitreuillé les autres ont embarqué
dans cette chaloupe de sauvetage et en
dépit d'un vent de force 8
les marins rescapés du pétrolier seront
tous y c'est sain et sauf à bord des
hélicoptères une grande partie des 26
membres d'équipage en majorité des
indiens a été recueillie à la base
aéronavale de lanvéoc-poulmic près de
brest
il raconte que depuis hier le navire
était parcourue de craquements
inquiétant avant finalement de se briser
ce matin à l'autre le temps était très
mauvais le navire avait du mal à faire
face
le temps était vraiment très mauvais et
le bateau n'était pas dans un très bon
état
c'était comme pour le titanic quand le
bateau s'est cassé on se tenait comme ça
sur le pont c'était comme sur le titanic
dans la journée deux remorqueurs dont le
très puissant abeille flandre ont fait
route sur la zone du naufrage
leur mission tenter de remorquer les
restes du pétrolier plus au large
l'épave est actuellement localisé à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres des côtes
et alors que les moyens de lutte contre
la pollution sont mises en oeuvre l'an
iv se poursuit cinq membres d'équipage
sont actuellement en garde à vue et
entendus par la gendarmerie dans le
cadre d'une enquête pour mise en danger
d'autrui
il est apparu en effet que le navire
était en mauvais état qu'il avait
demandé à se réfugier dans le port de
sanaa
une escale que le commandant de bord lui
a refusé voici l'instant filmé par la
marine nationale ou la coque de l'erika
s'est brisé en deux c'était dimanche
matin à 80 km des côtes bretonnes
on voit jaillir du pétrolier ventre et
des petits nuages noirs ce sont les
flots de fioul
dix minutes plus tard le navire sera
coupée en deux morceaux
comment en est on arrivé là c'est la
question à laquelle va tenter de
répondre la justice dès hier le parquet
de paris a ouvert une enquête un juge
d'instruction devrait être chargée
demain de cette affaire de mise en
danger d'autrui
mais d'ores et déjà cinq des 26 membres
indien de l'équipage de l'erika secouru
dimanche sont en garde à vue interrogé
par la gendarmerie maritime
parmi eux figurent le capitaine et le
second du pétrolier
ce navire battant pavillon maltais loué
par la firme total fina avait été
construit il ya 25 ans mais il avait
subi trois contrôles au cours des
derniers mois dont un en france samedi
après midi pourtant l'équipage a
découvert une avarie grave
une fissure dans la coque difficile à
contenir il a alors demandé à faire
escale dans le port de saint nazaire
mais le commandant du port a refusé pour
éviter semble-t-il tout risque de
pollution de la loire le commandant
alain chung aurait cependant aussitôt
prévenu la préfecture maritime de brest
mais en vain le pétrolier maltais qui
continue à faire route vers le sud dans
la tempête n'a pu aller plus loin c'est
le grand désarroi sur la petite île
droite située non loin de belle-ile là
bas encore aucun moyen n'a été acheminés
eric nejjar alain descormiers le long
des côtes de l'île de houat sur les
plages du béniguet du salut s'ils ne
peuvent qu'assister impuissant aux
dégâts provoqués par la pollution le
nettoyage n'a pas encore commencé pour
le moment comme partout on se contente
d'essayer de sauver les oiseaux mazoutés
échoué
c'est la seule chose qu'on a à faire
pour le moment et puis attendre que ça
se passe et puis les renforts qui arrive
peut-être
ce renfort on en a cruellement besoin
les plages les roches est touchée par la
pollution reste difficile d'accès et
l'on manque aussi de matériel ou hat est
une île qui ne dépasse pas les 350
habitants l'hiver one n'a pas ne possède
pas de magasin on peut les acheter comme
ça des pelles des débats des votes
certainement qu'il faudrait des
conteneurs des cirés pas les planches et
autres
enfin mode tout le matériel pour manger
les habitants de watts devront donc
patienter encore difficile de dire quand
arriveront les renforts la tempête aussi
empêche tous travaux de nettoyage sur
l'île on aurait préféré fêter noël
autrement ici en été c'est plein de
serviette dans une serviette des
maillots de bain c'est joli à voir et là
ces catastrophes catastrophe
j'ai quitté mon habit de père noël pour
aller ramasser le goudron voilà le noël
de l'an 2000 ça et encore what a échappé
au pire avant d'arriver sur l'île la
nappe de fioul échapper du pétrole erika
a trouvé sur son chemin
belle île en mer maigre consolation les
îliens savent qu'il faudra des mois au
mieux pour effacer toute trace de marée
noire dans notre pays cette tempête
accentue la pollution du littoral
atlantique ce matin au croisic la
population désemparée découvrez les
plages maculées de fioul échappée de
l'erika fabrice turpin nadine picard tôt
ce matin les habitants du croisic n'ont
pu que constater l'étendue des dégâts
les nappes de pétrole qui se sont
échappées de l'erika avait tout saccagé
pendant la nuit du croisic jusqu'à la
baule toute la côte sauvage plage
falaise creek était recouverte d'un
épais tapis marron noir gluant et
nauséabond mieux j'irai passer du poids
j'ai un copain qui m'a dit qu'elle va
sur mer le petit port c'était une flaque
de pétrole
je suis venu voir par curiosité puis
c'est pas possible je pensais même
qu'ils se moquer de moi quelque part et
pas trop à quoi du coup quand je vois ça
j'ai pas de mots pour exprimer sa c est
ce vous laisser comme ça pour rien faire
avec
enfin avec
le premier sentiment d'impuissance passé
ils ont pris leur propre matériel pelle
ciré bottes râteau tout ce qui leur
tombait sous la main pour tenter de
retrouver le visage originel de leur
littoral et moyens ils sont bien
organisés ici où c'est la débandade et
on peut je suis venu avec ma pelle comme
ça pas laisser la flèche ne l'était en
bronze là on va pas pas bronzer dans du
mazout à la marée noire ne fait en fait
que commencer une multitude de nappes de
10 15 20 mètres de diamètre ont été
repérés sur plus de 20 km à quelques
milles de la pointe du croisiens du tout
ces quelques notes quelques petites
galettes de fioul s'est pas de
catastrophe écologique
voilà le résultat dominique voynet
justement elle était aujourd'hui partout
en vendée en loire atlantique
histoire de faire oublier la polémique
de ces derniers jours c'est pas ça une
catastrophe et l'écologique madame
voynet et gagné contre elle oui hier non
les hanter bien vous ne parlez pas de
catastrophe écologique j'ai dit hier qu
avant que la pollution sera rivé sur les
plages on pouvait pas prédire en dire de
façon précise l'étendue et la gravité
dont quelques heures plus tard c'est
évident c'est une catastrophe écologique
de grande ampleur mais
ce n'est pas comme certains me précède
le derrière la catastrophe du siècle
il sera toutefois très difficile de
convaincre les habitants de piriac de la
turballe du croisic et de la baule car
ce soir ils savent que le pire est
encore à venir et l'image de marque de
la côte atlantique vient d'en prendre un
coup certains parlent de saison
complètement gâché ce soir ils n'ont
qu'une seule idée en tête
le pétrolier total fina doit payer et
depuis samedi
l'inquiétude était vive concernant l'île
de groix en face de lorient cette île
peuplée en hiver n'a pu être secouru que
ce matin et le bilan est encore plus
lourd que ce que l'on craignait
sur place les habitants sont désespérés
et se demandent s'ils retrouveront un
jour un littoral propres reste inopérant
qui s'abat seul complètement seul sur
cette plage face à l'étendue des dégâts
depuis vendredi cette île en face de
lorient subi de plein fouet l'arrivée
des nappes de pétrole l'aide du
continent n'a pu se déployer rapidement
en raison de la tempête alors contre
vents et marées les groisillons n'ont
donc pu que prendre leur courage à deux
mains pour lutter contre ce poison
gluant le goémon vient se coller au
mazout et c'est pratiquement impossible
à enlever à preuve regardez ces disques
comme tout
sa part en gros paquet et le pire c'est
qu'à chaque marée ce sera comme ça voilà
les nappes ont pris tout le monde de
court pas de dispositif prêt sur place
la menace était pourtant la tente car
groix est la première terre à l'est de
l'épave de l'erika les insulaires sont
consternés faut bien consommateurs
vivent comme une autre il
si on ne fait pas ça à personne le
frappe c'est désastreux en renfort 70
pompiers sont arrivés sur l'île mais
c'est maintenant le matériel qui manque
et le stockage qui fait défaut le sable
souillé entassés sur les plages repart à
la mère débordée aussi cette fois sur le
continent le centre de secours des
oiseaux montée en catastrophe avec sa
chaîne de bénévoles saturation ce n'est
plus qu'un centre de transit pour trier
les oiseaux et les évacuer au plus vite
vers la belgique où l'angleterre
personne n'imaginait une telle hécatombe
des oiseaux de mer des oiseaux vivant
sur la côte
tous ces frais les cartons s'entassent
et le nombre des victimes dépasse déjà
largement celui des autres marée noire
en france
ministre de l'économie a par ailleurs
annoncé deux bonnes nouvelles pour les
sinistrés premièrement il n'y aura pas
de franchise supérieur à 1500 francs
pour les assurés christian sautter qui a
précisé ensuite qu'après un accord avec
les compagnies d'assurances les visites
d'experts ne seront pas nécessaires si
les travaux sont inférieures à 20 mille
francs
sur le front de la marée noire toujours
pas de bonnes nouvelles la pollution
progresse vers le sud
et on apprend par ailleurs que le
pompage du fioul contenu dans l'épave de
l'erika ne pourra pas être entrepris
avant plusieurs mois stéphane breitner
depuis des jours
ces mêmes scènes de ramassage du pétrole
sur les plages ce matin encore à la
turballe on s'activait pour effacer ses
immenses taches noires polluants
des scènes que l'on s'attend à revoir
bientôt encore plus au sud
parce que l'ana progrès elle se trouve
maintenant au large de
talmont-saint-hilaire après être passé
au nord-est de l'île durant là souriant
elle se déplace à grande vitesse aidé
par la tempête qui la rapproche des
côtes
le dernier survol du site où s'est
échouée l'erika n'a pas ramené de bonnes
nouvelles
des dizaines de boulettes de pétrole
remonte à la verticale de lait par une
épave dont on ne sait toujours pas dans
quel état elle se trouve hier le na'vi
abbaye supporters a quitté bayonne avec
à bord un robot téléguidé qui a
notamment servi à inspecter l'épave du
titanic par 120 mètres de fond grâce à
ses caméras et ses deux bras articulé il
pourra fournir les premières images de
la coque de l'erika et repérer les
fuites à ce que monde exactement comme
un jeu vidéo vous avez un joystick et
toutes les fonctions de propulsion de
rotation sont commandés par ce joystick
le navire avec ses 11 hommes d'équipage
doit arriver sur site en fin d'après
midi
si la météo le permet aujourd'hui ce
sont plus de 250 km de côtes qui sont
touchés par la marée noire
et ce n'est sans doute pas fini
les 20 mille tonnes de fuel encore
prisonnières dans la coque de l'erika
menace les spécialistes estiment que les
opérations de pompage ne pourront pas
débuter avant le printemps et dans les
communes touchées par la marée noire on
hésite là aussi à maintenir les
festivités prévues pour le passage à
l'an 2000
nos envoyés spéciaux loire atlantique à
ce moulin farber et philippe turpault
était ce matin à la boule pour essayer
de savoir si les habitants de cette
région se préparait à faire le réveillon
malgré tout au marché de la baule on
prépare tranquillement la soirée du
réveillon en essayant d'oublier la marée
noire
en tout cas peut-être un peu tristounet
avec ses collègues du pouliguen et de
pornichet le maire de la baule avait
prévu d'embraser la baie sur 9 km mais
l'ambiance ne coïncide pas avec ce grand
show tout est annulé
la france à 83 morts nous nous sommes
des communes sinistrées nous avons reçu
vous allez recevoir des aides de l'état
du pipole et il ya un seul mot qui me
paraît aujourd'hui convenable c'est
celui de solidarité avec tous ceux qui
souffrent ces événements aussi bien des
tempêtes que de la marée noire
donc je ne crois pas que le coeur il
soit beaucoup à des manifestations de ce
genre pas de feu d'artifice mais cet
hôtel restaurant n'a pas eu de
désistement
il faut préparer les 100 couverts pour
ce réveillon ordinaire on a des gens qui
avaient choisi leur table et tout pour
être aux premières loges ce qu'on est
juste face à la mer est bon c'est
dommage que tout ça soit soit annulée
c'est un petit peu de la fête qui s'en
va mais mon le coeur n'y était pas la
plage avec la marée noire la plage et en
juillet tout ça seul un rayon de soleil
éclaire la plage elle devait être une
esplanade de fait c'est un grand
chantier
les services techniques travailleront
jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit
depuis hier la marée noire touche l'île
de ré les premières galettes
d'hydrocarbure ont fait leur apparition
dans la nuit de la saint-sylvestre
poussé par la marée une dizaine de
tonnes de pétrole aurait été ramassés
pour la seule journée d'hier et
volontaires sont à pied d'oeuvre et ce
matin apparemment la situation est moins
polluante
reportage françois privat philippe
ritaine
c'est oiseaux mazoutés s'est échoué
cette nuit au nord de l'île de ré
impossible pour lui de reprendre son vol
il se laisse même capturer facilement
[Musique]
mais malade vous êtes on peut sauver un
carton dans la voiture
greg est un surfeur américain ils
fréquentent tout au long de l'année les
plages et les bagues rethel ce matin à
saint clément des baleines
il est l'un des premiers à gratter les
rochers doigts si on ne suit pas très
religieux je vais pas trop souvent à
metz mais ici c'est mon église
la mère sarah croissante dieu ça reste
pour moi c'est quelque chose de très
profond des fois ça c'est comme si vous
devez mis ça dans ma cuisine dans mon
église c'est ça ma révolte absolue entre
saint clément les baleines les portes et
ars en ré on a déjà ramassé plus de 14
tonnes de pétrole sans compter les
oiseaux monde actuellement un
hélicoptère de la sécurité civile survol
des rivages à la recherche d'éventuels
n'a pas la dérive ou encore de trace
d'hydrocarbure plus au sud de l'île
on vient de découvrir de nouvelles
nappes arrivés ces dernières heures est
la plus claire non cet après-midi les
affaires maritimes et des pêcheurs de
l'île de ré pourrait tenter de chaluter
plusieurs nappes qui dérivait au large
alors que le pétrole de l'erika continue
de souiller les plages de vendée de
loire atlantique on redoute une deuxième
marée noire des pêcheurs ont constaté
des remontées de fioul près de l'épave
les images filmées par leurs beaux
habits sub montre que la partie arrière
du pétrolier ne présente pas de fissure
comme on le redoutait
mais le problème est que ce robot n'a
pas pu inspecter la totalité de la coque
jacques devaux gabriel camilla voilà ce
que l'habit subles robots sous-marins a
pu voir de l'épave de l'erika lors de
ses deux premières plongées une dizaine
d'heures d'investigation sur les 2/3 de
l'épave
avant que le robot ne se bloquent mais
les experts sont formels la partie
inspecté de l'erika ne fuit pas on n'a
rien vu comme fuite
absolument
on n'a pas vu de suite alors on nous dit
les marins pêcheurs disent il ya des
irisations surface il est un peu
d'irritation surface mais j'appelle pas
ça une fille c'est pas
c'est sûrement pas en tout cas du
chargement parce que ces chargements
vous avez vu comment cela s'est vu sur
les plages ça n'est pas du tout le cas
donc
maintenant pour savoir il faudra
analyser le produit mais tout le monde
n'a interprète pas les choses tout à
fait de la même façon jean pierre salaun
président du comité local des pêches de
concarneau était d'abord de l'abeille
supporter pour lui les irisations
visibles en surface la supposée des
fuites
en surface on voit simplement dessus de
la pollution mais minime mais pourquoi
baky et certaines parties de la de droit
la déchirure qu'il y ait des fissures et
que le pétrole au mans mais c'est à gros
bouillons ce n'est pas à vous mouiller
on voit comment du 5 septembre sur fasse
tache d'huile
loin de rassurer la mission non achevé
de l'abysse hub laisse encore beaucoup
de questions sans réponse les experts
réclament du temps et des analyses plus
poussées
la population elle voudrait être
rassurés tout de suite la marée noire
maintenant une autre bataille médiatique
dans l'actualité le travail effectué par
la société total pour redresser un peu
son image
c'est d'abord le pdg qui monté hier au
créneau pour l'instant les appels au
boycott ne sont pas vraiment très suivi
reportage de nos stations régionales
commenté par laurent de baisse initié
par les verts le boycott des pompes à
essence total est avant tout symbolique
si quelques graffitis apparaissent sur
les murs de certaines stations comme ici
à albi les clients affichent fidélité et
bon sens se sépare de l'enfant'' c'est
le bateau a coulé et j'estime que les
gens qui ont pris le temps de faire au
sein et avec à paris au palais un saut
est allé là bas
même son de cloche de la part des
consommateurs de la côte d'opale on ne
remet pas en cause la responsabilité du
pétrolier mais on suggère un règlement
plus strict sur le transport des
matières polluantes que je sois clients
chez total wire le problème est le même
la règle et récap très bien a fait
affréter paravent pétrolier total
la solution consiste en une une
interdiction des bateaux en mauvais état
donc à l'interdiction des des pavillons
de complaisance donc à l'interdiction
des compagnies de certification
un peu boiteuse comme celle qui en
dernier lieu avait sorti fils l'erika le
groupe total a mis du temps à réagir
face à l'ampleur de la marée noire
sentant le vent de la colère s'amplifier
thierry desmarest pdg de la compagnie
pétrolière a annoncé hier la création
d'une mission littoral atlantique des
sociétés privées est payé par le groupe
pétrolier est chargée de nettoyer
différents sites soulier sur le terrain
comme ici à moëlan-sur-mer les bénévoles
s'impatiente prendre leurs
responsabilités pour tenter de redorer
une image ternie par cette catastrophe
écologique total se lance donc dans une
opération de séduction envers les
consommateurs et sans doute aussi envers
les marchés financiers le désastre
écologique provoquée par la marée noire
avec ces chiffres affolants plus de 300
mille oiseaux seraient souillé par le
mazout
à l'heure actuelle un dixième d'entre
eux a été recueillie sur le littoral
atlantique où tout est fait pour les
aider à survivre l'entr'aide
internationale avec l'arrivée de
spécialistes américains anglais que
c'est dans le morbihan près de vannes
louis carzou et marcel martin ont suivi
l'un des quatorze vétérinaire en mission
les images qui vont suivre sont parfois
difficiles sur les plages abandonnées
c'est une chanson que connaît bien dans
rock donald car c'était cosset de 34 ans
est un spécialiste des marées noires de
l'arabie séoudite à la nouvelle zélande
mais lorsqu'il s'est retrouvé
aujourd'hui sur la plage de saint
jacques dans le golfe du morbihan
il avait la triste impression d'être un
peu à la maison c'est particulièrement
éprouvant pour moi parce que c'est fou
de bassan donc sur cette plage et ce
n'est la récolte que de la dernière
l'arrêt eh bien ce sont des oiseaux qui
se reproduisent en écosse chez moi d'une
certaine manière il rentra chez eux
baroque est arrivé ce matin au centre de
tep rade bad avec 13 autres vétérinaire
biologiste et spécialistes animaliers
venus de grande bretagne des états unis
et d'afrique du sud
leur mission rendre plus efficace le
travail des 130 bénévoles du centre car
maintenir la température nettoyer les
plumages ou assurer la nourriture chaque
soin apporté aux oiseaux mazoutés doit
suivre un protocole précis
attention là il faut éviter la glotte
comme pour effectuer sa première
réhydratation de guillemot
d'accord mais on voit que leur état
évolue ça nous donne encore plus ça nous
motive encore plus il est d'experts
rendu publicis et encore par l'ampleur
des dégâts sur la faute car pour se
rendre compte de l'étendue du massacre
da rocha n'est pas allé sur une nouvelle
plage vous à la déchetterie municipale
de st les oiseaux c'est ce qu'il y a les
jours évident dans une marée noire on
les voit couverts de mazout mais les
gens doivent être conscients que leur
pétrole pollue tout absolument tout
l'écosystème il ne faut surtout pas se
dire bof
après tout ce ne sont que des oiseaux se
nourrissent pas formée dans le golfe du
morbihan pour recenser le nombre
d'oiseaux morts c'est désormais la tonne
qui sert d'unité de mesure
si l'on peut encore parler de mesures
dans ce qu'il convient d'appeler
''l'affaire du naufrage erika cette
information donnée par nos confrères de
libération selon laquelle la compagnie
shell aurait jugé inacceptable l'état du
pétrolier pour le transport de son
propre fioul
une nouvelle révélation à charge qui met
en cause pour le mois une certaine forme
de laxisme de total fina la société qui
a aussitôt répliqué en rejetant toute
responsabilité sur les autorités
chargées de l'inspection des navires
patrick fandio
c'est un témoignage qui fait des vagues
à la une de libération
le quotidien a interrogé un inspecteur
de la compagnie pétrolière shell un
homme qui affirme qu après une
inspection janvier 99
il a été signalé à l'armateur que les
ricaines ne pouvaient transporter de
cargaisons chaînes en clair une sorte de
veto car pour la compagnie anglo
néerlandaise
le pétrolier n'était pas assez sur un
jugement
apparemment partagée par d'autres
compagnies du moins si l'on en croit le
rapport de la commission d' enquête du
ministère des transports
d'après ce document depuis septembre 96
pratiquement aucun des grands groupes
pétroliers n'a frété verica seul total a
affrété le navire
quatre fois en 1999 total qui se défend
ce soir d'être la moins exigeante des
compagnies pétrolières nos critères
d'affrètement sont exactement les mêmes
que ceux de shell nous faisons partie de
la même organisation qui s'appelle le
cir est si heureux et nous avons les
mêmes critères d'inspection et le même
type d'inspecteurs seulement sur la base
des rapports techniques de leurs
inspecteurs les compagnies pétrolières
tirent des interprétations fort
différente par souci de sécurité
certaines d'entre elles ont adopté
d'autres critères de sélection des
navires il est clair que la décision
d'affréter un navire repose bien sûr sur
son état technique mais aussi sur son
adaptabilité au trafic bien déterminé
que peut avoir telle ou telle compagnie
à ses exigences propres voire à la
situation financière de l'affréteur la
commission denquête le disais hier pour
qu'il y ait peu ou plus d'erika il
faudrait entre autres que les compagnies
pétrolières soit à nouveau propriétaire
des navires qu'elle utilise une
perspective qui a peu de chance de se
réaliser dans un secteur maritime ont
sévi une féroce concurrent ganja spa
avait déplacé une partie de son
gouvernement en bretagne aujourd'hui il
s'agissait de mois et demi après la
marée noire de l'erika
bah non c'est un nouveau coup de pouce
gouvernemental 5 milliards de francs
vont être débloqués sur quatre ans dont
un milliard dès cette année des mesures
qui ne semble pas avoir apaisé la colère
des ostréiculteurs qui ont bruyamment
manifesté dans les rues de nantes
reportage album et cosy patrick
descheemaecker
pas de tension perceptible pas
d'allusions au voyage au proche-orient à
nantes
lionel jospin présidé un conseil
interministériel consacré aux
conséquences des tempêtes et de la marée
noire
douze ministres des sommes importantes
débloquer l'objectif est de faire
oublier les cafouillages de la fin
décembre avec un plan d'indemnisation
complet la réponse de l'état a été forte
et rapide
elle est forte par les montants engagés
au total pour faire face aux
conséquences des deux ouragans comme à
celle de la marée noire
les mesures arrêtées représente un
effort budgétaire de 4 milliard 600
millions de francs pour l'année 2000
sont concernés les professionnels du
tourisme mais aussi d'autres secteurs
économiques sont sinistrés comme les
ostréiculteurs et pêcheurs qui ont
profité de l'occasion pour manifester
leur désarroi
certains d'entre eux étant même venus
surtout pour en découdre
les manifestants sont repartis le calme
est revenu sur nantes mais lionel jospin
c'est que d'autres épreuves l'attendent
à commencer par les questions au
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale où
les députés de l'opposition ne
manqueront pas de lui parler de ses
propos
israël malgré cette aide et celle
annoncée lundi à nantes lors du comité
interministériel les habitants du
littoral atlantique sont toujours en
colère
à saint-nazaire un collectif anti marée
noire vient de lancer une pétition pour
abroger un protocole de 92 qui modifiait
la loi internationale en matière
d'indemnisation des pollutions maritimes
un texte qui vous allez le comprendre
des douanes les pétroliers pollueurs les
explications de christine le héros
depuis le naufrage de l'erika d'une
seule voix les militants anti marée
noire vise total fina pour eux le
pollueur et le payeur or total fina ne
peut pas être poursuivi c'est la loi
internationale qui le dit pourquoi
pascal braud a trouvé la réponse dans ce
texte de 92 signé notamment par la
france
il modifie la précédente convention de
69 tout affréteurs d'un navire est
exonéré de poursuites en cas de marée
noire
c'est à dire que concrètement la société
total est exonéré de toutes poursuites
civiles
sur le plan de la marée noire donc on
peut toujours taper sur total c'est
l'état qui va payer plein pot la facture
en 92 le nouveau texte signé notamment
par le gouvernement français augmente
sensiblement le fonds d'indemnisation
mais dans le même temps effectivement
les pétroliers eux se mettent à l'abri
c'est ainsi que e a été constituée en 92
sous la pression très forte des
compagnies pétrolières une un mur
juridique faisant qu'elle était à moins
que ce soit sur leurs propres flottes
qu'elle était en dehors de la
responsabilité et des propriétaires de
navires et du fipol ce fonds
international d'indemnisation
seule une faute grave pourrait entraîner
des poursuites judiciaires et
financières contre total fina une faute
grave comme par exemple avoir transporté
une matière illégal ce que démontrent
les premières analyses de ce laboratoire
indépendant est par contre il est prouvé
qu'il s'agit pas d'un produits
valorisables mais bien un péché de
raffineries à ce moment là le principe
de libre circulation ne s'applique plus
est pas une marchandise ou valorisables
il aurait fallu appliquer le principe de
proximité qui exclut toute exportation
et qui impose même la destruction dans
les règles dans l'installation de
destruction la plus proche du lieu de
production et pour en avoir le coeur net
ce laboratoire critiqué pour ses
analyses demande une contre expertise
pour prouver si oui ou non total fina
peut-être finalement poursuivi campagne
publicitaire et discours rassurant les
communes touchées par la pollution de
l'erika tente par tous les moyens
d'éviter une désaffection des touristes
à belle-ile par exemple on poursuit le
nettoyage des plages et les
professionnels multiplient les
opérations de séduction yasmina farber
blaise grenier
bélisle sort de l'hiver d'une torpeur
liées à la marée noire
b lille retrouve un air de vacances et
les vacances tout le monde y pense car
les appels pour les demandes
d'informations sur les séjours se font
rares 67 % de moins par rapport à l'an
dernier
les bellilois s'interroge sur une bonne
stratégie de communication
il constate les dégâts économiques de la
pollution à trois semaines des vacances
de pâques
[Musique]
nous avons commencé à envisager
ce désastre au niveau économique sur
l'île à partir de début février et c'est
là que les autorités de l'île ont pris
conscience que le secteur touristique
allait toucher aussi après le caractère
écologique
le malaise est bien réel les offres
d'emploi sont plus que limités pour la
saison c'est le constat d'une
association de belle-ile qui recense les
besoins des professionnels donc au
l'année dernière on avait à peu près à
la même époque 200 propositions d'offres
d'emploi et qu'aujourd'hui on a une
vingtaine une vraie fuite et met en
corner après losique couteau ils
attendent cela on économiques pour
rassurer les vacanciers la dépollution
les plus grosses nappes de fioul ont
disparu le réseau fignolage une
responsable de l'office du tourisme a
voulu nous montrer une plage grand
public celle de bord dardot et
elle est même très très très profond
vous pouvez y aller tout est
impeccablement propres et toute façon
cet été il y aura des machines qui
systématiquement viendront nettoyer tous
des plages de toutes les plages le matin
au moment de l'été ou même de l'avant
saison et tous les jours actuellement
elle face à belle-ile le travail de
réhabilitation est en marche mais toute
la côte atlantique va communiquer
campagne d'affichage publicités
télévisées 60 millions de francs pour
lancer un slogan anti marée noire
respirez vous êtes en france atlantique
alors que les opérations de pompage ont
repris hier sur la partie arrière cette
fois de l'épave de l'erika permettant de
récupérer 870 tonnes de fioul
l'heure est au premier bilan pour les
stations touristiques de la façade
atlantique touchés par la marée noire de
décembre dernier sur l'île de
noirmoutier les bilans des quinze
premiers jours de juillet est plutôt
rassurant même si on enregistre une
baisse de la fréquentation sur place
christophe de vallon bras et alain
darrigrand
ils sont moins nombreux que d'habitude
sur les plages de noirmoutier mais ils
sont tout de même venus aujourd'hui
lille a totalement effacé les traces de
l'erika mais ici on savait que l'image
des boulettes de fioul sur le sable
serait beaucoup plus tenaces
on craignait même une saison
catastrophique en fait la première
quinzaine de juillet plutôt rassurantes
la baisse de fréquentation est certaine
mais elle n'est pas aussi importante
qu'on pouvait le craindre
ça tourne plus autour de -20 % que moins
30 moins 50 % comme on a pu craindre à
une certaine époque mais ces premiers
chiffres sont très variables la
principale baisse touche les locations
une clientèle souvent familial est donc
très attiré par la plage en termes
d'image de marque
on a relativement souffert de
ce qui s'est passé là on constate en
termes de demande qu'on a à peu près
moitié moins que d'habitude de demandes
de location simplement et en termes de
réservations là on a nettement un bon
quart d'heure
- touché les campings de lille
enregistrent une baisse de fréquentation
d'environ 15%
mais la situation s'améliore avec la
météo les féeries cas devrait lui être
limité
ce que nous pouvons enregistrer comme
baisse sensible de 10 voire 5%
actuellement
nora je pense pas d'incidence jeu du
moins je l'espère sur l'ensemble de la
saison pour les restaurateurs en
revanche aucun problème certains avaient
même sous-estimer leurs besoins en
personnel les premiers jours de juillet
ont été excellents on a été un petit peu
aidé par mauvais temps qui nous a ramené
beaucoup de passage sur l'île en fait on
a récupéré une grande partie de la
course ajournement
adam
la boule mais tous les chiffres de cette
première quinzaine ne sont que des
indices il faudra bien sûr attendre la
fin de la saison sur l'île pour mesurer
le véritable impact de la marée noire
un an après des équipes de dépollution
sont toujours au travail dans les zones
essentiellement rocheuses c'est ce que
nous allons voir sur l'île dedic qui se
situe au large du golfe du morbihan des
opérations nettoyage laborieuse dans des
conditions difficiles qui vont prendre
encore des mois hélène peu de chez
philippe bouchet lendemain de tempête à
eddy dans un vent assourdissant des
hommes en blanc sera que la moindre
trace de pétrole
un pareil trie les galets
avant de les rendre à la crique la
pollution arrivée sur une zone où il y
avait que des galets et depuis le sablar
couverte ces zones
donc au fur à mesure on reprend les
zones qui se dé caisse naturellement
pour éviter
évidemment de d'enlever manuellement
donc là on retraite une zone qui a déjà
été travaillé par les militaires il ya
en début d'été cette deuxième phase de
dépollution a démarré il ya deux mois
après les plages nettoyer dans l'urgence
pour accueillir quelques touristes 7
autour des zones rocheuses et des
criques de galets un travail long et
minutieux assurée par cinq pompiers du
plan polmar est une entreprise de
dépollution engagé par total en tout
trente personnes
ici pas de tracteur ni même de voitures
tout se fait à la main c'est facile tous
les jours
à genoux dans les cailloux et puis
s'élevant surtout il vend aussi c'est
tout le temps tout en tout temps donc ça
tu as eu le nettoyage devrait durer
jusqu'en juin au moins pour passer tout
l'hiver sur l'île les des pollueurs sont
logés dans ces mobiles homes le soir au
goût il retrouve les îliens l'erika n'a
pas seulement marqué les côtes dans les
esprits aussi elle a laissé son
empreinte
quand il ya des gros temps comme ça on
est inquiet c'est sûr que tant que les
mesures niveau de l'état seront pas
prises un peu plus strictes ça sera on
sera toujours présent et
là on y pense tous les jours on a des
gens qui naîtra quotidiennement ils
vivent avec nous
d'habitude sur l'île on est 80 on passe
à 100 les enfants n'ont plus n'oublie
pas ses dessins date d'il ya quinze
jours
malgré cela les écoliers préfère retenir
chaque signe d'espoir et les mouettes
reviennent positon tous quoi
[Musique]
et ça tu es content de revoir les moyens
ces temps ci
vendredi soir sur le port les dépôts
lueur repartent passer le week-end sur
le continent petit à petit et dick se
défait de sa ceinture noire en un an 730
tonnes de déchets mazoutés ont été
retirés édition spéciale nous sommes à
la turballe en loire atlantique
magnifique petit port de pêche breton
pourquoi et bien tout simplement pour
marquer l'anniversaire terrible de la
catastrophe écologique de l'erika
c'était exactement il y a un an le 12
décembre 99 du fioul qui vient polluer
plus de 400 kilomètres de côtes
souvenirs patrick fandio il s'imagine à
cet instant là ils ont encore une chance
qu'ils peuvent encore remorqué au large
la partie arrière du méritas
il est 14 heures ce lundi 13 décembre 99
les hommes de la belle plante vivre d'un
combat inégal
un vent de force 9 des creux de 8 à 10 m
une lutte désespérée pour éviter une
pollution massive mais il n'y a plus
rien à faire
c'est la fin d'une longue agonie
commencé 18 heures plus tôt le
remorqueur et les autorités ont été
prévenus trop tard
l'erika est resté trop longtemps un
navire silencieux
à bord du pétrolier ont ce samedi 11
décembre veille du naufrage on ne
pouvait ignorer la gravité de la
situation
la preuve cette liaison radio à 14h48
entre le capitaine de l' erika et le
ford george le navire anglais qui a
entendu le premier message de détresse
[Applaudissements]
m
un pont cassé jamais le capitaine de l'
erika nous donnera cette information
capitale au procès tel dans les heures
qui suivent dans ce telex envoyer trente
minutes plus tard il affirme même que la
situation est sous contrôle et annule
son message de détresse
une erreur ou un mensonge car ou bateau
qui est rentré chez lui en inde et mises
en examen au cross etel pendant le
naufrage
on a tout enregistré toutes les liaisons
de l'erika pourquoi il n'a donc pas eu
de surveillance spéciale autour du
pétrolier pourquoi personne n'a pris la
mesure de ce qui se passait pourquoi la
préfecture maritime a été alerte et si
tard
trois officiers sont mises en examen
dont le commissaire de l'ue ici à droite
biella au monténégro c'est dans ce port
que l'erika est censé avoir subi de
grosses réparations des réparations
douteuses dans un chantier naval
spécialisé dans les travaux à moindre
coût grâce à ces travaux
l'erika avait tous ces certificats en
rêve tous visés par hina la société de
classification italienne est soupçonné
d'avoir manqué de vigilance
on sous-estimé l'effet de la corrosion
six de ses employés dont le responsable
technique massimo volta sont mises en
examen également mise en examen le
gestionnaire du pétrolier antonio
pollara et le propriétaire italien
giuseppe savarese la juge dominique de
talancé poursuit son enquête
un an après on est encore très loin d'un
éventuel procès
ce qui s'est infligé qu'on a mis en
place civière eh bien regardez on l'a
retrouvé ce matin
c'est pas remplies de pétrole hier il
était vert à willi weber comme ce qu'on
peut voir sur
cette plage ils l'ont pourtant nettoyer
hier mais aujourd'hui tout est déjà
refaire difficile à admettre pour ces
hommes de la sécurité civile qui en sont
à leur quatrième séjour ici ça fait un
an qu'on vient jour en jour on est
toujours mais moins pressants pour
avancer
1 c'est un peu décourageant pour ça
ainsi va la dépollution des plages au
gré des marées des tempêtes qui ramène
périodiquement des plaques de fioul
trente deux chantiers sont encore en
cours pourtant il faut le dire le
répéter
95% des plages de loire-atlantique sont
propres la reconquête aura pris une
année et coûté 400 millions de francs
rien qu'à l'état elle aura aussi permis
de prendre conscience de l'importance de
ce patrimoine qui ne s'entretient pas
tout seul marée noire ou pas on oublie
c'est notre or blanc et la marée noire
nous a bien montré que 1
le touriste il fallait aller le chercher
aujourd'hui pour générer les emplois qui
y sont liés puis deux
il fallait qu'on travaille des plages et
la décision qui a été prise par exemple
à pornichet c'est que contrairement aux
autres années
dès le mois d'avril on va chercher à
mettre les plages en très bon état
n'exagérons rien quand même la marée
noire n'a rien d'une bonne affaire pour
les communes sinistrées
mesquer 1300 habitants a dépensé près
d'un million de francs en un an
autant d'argent en moins pour d'autres
priorités le fleurissement de la commune
vous avez des tas de choses comme ça qui
sont importantes et qu'on a un petit peu
laissé à l'abandon
c'est certain pendant n sans parler du
personnel qui a été utilisé uniquement
pour nettoyer et s'occuper des plages
madame le maire sait de quoi elle parle
elle vient de perdre un procès contre
total à qui elle réclamait le
remboursement de ses dépenses
le littoral est aujourd'hui à peu près
propre désormais le combat s'est déplacé
de la plage au prétoire pour la nettoyer
on a indemnisé on continue de travailler
vous l'avez vu mais beaucoup d'opposants
ont voulu commémorer à leur façon cet
anniversaire ce premier anniversaire de
la catastrophe de l'erika lors c'était
vrai pour le rameur jo le guen qui a
occupé le siège de la mission littoral
de total en inde
et c'était vrai aussi ce matin pour les
manifestants qui eux sont allés voir le
siège du fipol c'est le fonds
d'indemnisation internationale à lorient
au portage d'olivier sion et de michel
hiver la confédération maritime avait
annoncé un simple pique nique se suit en
fait à gages en règle de la succursale
du fipol à lorient
[Applaudissements]
observons donc pour la féminisation j'ai
créé un bureau c'est un anniversaire
comme tout anniversaire ça se fête
j'ai 30 ans quand j'ai 30 ans mais
trente bougies bas c'est leur première
quoi donc bon anniversaire
toujours pour l'indemnisation à ce jour
là puis immédiatement après le
responsable de la confédération maritime
alain malardé a été interpellé non sans
difficulté j'étais gay ça met des
vitrines ils ont tagué 400 km de plage
est ce que vous vous arrêtez moi je vais
m'arrêter vous arrêtez démarré en même
temps désir après midi la coordination
des collectifs anti marée noire et
quelques paludiers de guérande avaient
envahi les locaux de la mission littoral
de total à nantes à leurs côtés et dans
le rôle du porte drapeau
le rameur jo le guen il y aura un après
erika qui à terme ne peut pas être comme
l'avant eric l'erika doit être le
naufrage de trop qui va faire que les
choses doivent changer
vont changer ça va pas être facile ça va
sans doute être long pour spectaculaire
qu'elle soit cette action de la
confédération maritime n'a réuni qu'un
nombre limité de participants
de fait aujourd'hui un an après le
naufrage de l'erika les organisations
semblent avoir du mal à fédérer les
oppositions pourtant réel à total et aux
fipol le terrible anniversaire de cette
catastrophe écologique de l'erika
c'était il ya un an exactement le 12
décembre 99 le pétrolier maltais là-bas
dans l'océan se casser en deux et
souillait plus de 400 kilomètres de
côtes avec un coût total pour cette
catastrophe
depuis 3 milliards de francs alors
évidemment à l'époque catastrophe pour
la pêche catastrophe pour le tourisme
catastrophe pour les huîtres aussi et
pour les coqs
tout ça est rentré dans l'ordre
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque on s'est beaucoup inquiété
alors les coques justement tintin est
très très content de venir dans la
région
le petit garçon pourquoi parce que le
croisic est le premier producteur de
coqs en france ces coques en stock
tulu tout près d'ici du côté de guérande
si professionnellement tout est rentré
dans l'ordre
il faut manger des huîtres il faut
manger les coques elles sont très bonnes
aujourd'hui en revanche c'est vrai que
le traumatisme a été marqué pendant très
très longtemps reportage de jacques
devaux et michel hiver
à quelques jours des fêtes de noël
l'activité bat son plein dans le crêt du
croisic premières zones d'élevage de
coqs en france
pour pascal chaullet comme pour ses
confrères le naufrage de l'erika n'est
plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
et pourtant la pêche ici a été interdite
pendant cinq mois
hainard est ouvert que le 13 juin
dernier le consommateur par contre
n'auraient pas compris que ainsi toucher
ne soit pas marqué par une fermeture
donc je crois que la fermeture était un
mal nécessaire il ya d'ailleurs eu
aucune protestation du milieu
professionnel en avril dernier pour en
finir avec la pollution les
professionnels du secteur n'avait pas
ménagé leurs efforts
prenant même la pelle pour nettoyer
l'entrée du très du croisic ou une nappe
de pétrole polluer l'eau de mer
on est dedans on va dominer le nettoyage
on va avancer de 20 mètres par jour et
puis petit à petit on l'aura aujourd'hui
les machines à récolter les coques ont
remplacé les pelleteuses mais les 16
entreprises du secteur ont subi un
préjudice de 8 millions de francs
pendant toute la fermeture pascal
chollet a perdu entre 2 et 300 mille
francs par mois
une perte prise en charge par la
collectivité et les entreprises ont tout
de suite été alimentée globalement par
des avances trésorerie qui couvrait une
grande partie du préjudice
donc maintenant on attend on attend que
le fipol paye pour pouvoir rembourser
les prêteurs que sont le département et
la région
et si le fipol ne paye pas tout le
préjudice l'état s'est engagé à verser
la différence
mais si professionnellement les traces
du naufrage ont été effacés pascal
chaullet conserve une grande rancoeur
envers total
je suis professionnel mais je suis
contribuable et le contribuable est
révolté parce que ça nous coûte cher et
j'ai l'impression que le coupable se
découpe pas cher ce qui fait que j'ai
peur qu'on n'ait pas fait grand chose
pour éviter la suivante
aujourd'hui parce qu'à se tourner vers
l'avenir l'an prochain il va investir
dans une nouvelle machine à récolter les
coques erika n'aura pas tuer la
profession on se retrouve maintenant sur
la plage du pouliguen sur la côte
sauvage où on est en train de travailler
encore et on en train de nettoyer encore
les professionnels du tourisme pour tout
le littoral atlantique
on évalue à peu près les pertes de
recettes à -30% pour l'été 1999 dues à
la catastrophe de l'erika et pour
certains ça a été même beaucoup plus que
ça c'est le cas par exemple d'antonio
calvo que je vais rejoindre maintenant
le requise elle son petit restaurant qui
est là haut il a été fermé il a été
fermé pendant très longtemps pendant
cinq mois et demi du 26è 199
pratiquement jusqu'à la mi-mai et on
nous a fermé la route bien sûr pour la
sécurité c'est tout à fait normal ce que
je comprends mais nous on nous a mis au
chômage obligatoire est obligé quoi pour
une problème finalement qui nous
concernait pas
donc c'est passé c'est la cata pour nous
c'est donc plus de clients pendant plus
de cinq mois et bien malheureusement
plus de clients plus de chiffre
d'affaires et puis peut malheureusement
suspension des décommandé crédit que
l'on peut avoir sur cet établissement et
puis bah voilà quoi oui l'indemnisation
comment ça s'est passé alors à
l'indemnisation c'était malheureusement
c'était pendant cinq mois et demi
c'était vraiment un mur parce qu'on ne
pouvait pas le le gros problème que l'on
avait c'était de justifier de notre
isolement parce qu'on nous disait oui
mais vous êtes comme tous les
restaurateurs vous attendrez la fin de
saison pour savoir l'indemnité disco là
nous on ne pouvait pas travailler parce
que la route était bouché il ya aucune
voiture qu'il passait donc l'indemnité
ben on sait pendant cinq mois et demi
c'était vraiment le mur
et puis je vais dire grâce ou alors à
cause bon c'est vrai que france 2 est
venue un jour chez nous parce qu'ils ont
trouvé vraiment qu'on avait une
situation particulière excusez moi je
suis un peu ému mais bon et puis à
partir de jour là alors comme par
enchantement
quarante huit heures après le fipol nous
appelle votre dossier il manque telle et
telle pièce si vous voulez que ça avance
enfin
ça a commencé à se dénouer et du jour où
la route a été réouverte on a travaillé
on a travaillé parce que bon les
français ont été super sympa parce
qu'ils ont été solidaires
l'ajustement je remercie tout à fait les
gens qui sont venus nous voir parce que
c'était pas c'était pas pratique
c'était pas une côte superbe mans
nettoyer bon mais les gens sont venus il
ya une semaine
une solidarité qui s'est fait et j'avoue
que j'ai été vraiment très touché et ça
même beaucoup ému et je disais aussi que
la plupart des plages 95% des plages sur
littoral atlantique sont propres
aujourd'hui il en reste quand même
regarder il en reste quand même on le
voit le fioul ça nous fait un préjudice
de 200 mille francs près au lieu de 22
semaines en 99 jeunes et louis que onze
semaines pour cet ami j'ai été voir mon
comptable et hier il m'a annoncé - 30 %
dans le secteur du tourisme les campings
sont les plus touchés le propriétaire de
ce terrain quatre étoiles a subi un
préjudice de 400 mille francs en plein
mois d'août et une alloué que le quart
des emplacements et des mobile homes les
vacanciers anglais et allemands qui
d'habitude représente la moitié de sa
clientèle ne sont pas venus du tout
alors comme 85% de ses confrères du
morbihan les ongs et elle a fait une
demande d'indemnisation les dossiers
c'est ici qu'on vient les déposer dans
cette structure mise en place par le
conseil général et les chambres de
commerce
après contrôle les comptables
transmettent aux fipol le fonds
international qui indemnise en cas de
pollution par hydrocarbures noval 70 %
de chiffre d'affaires insurmontable ce
couple qui loi des mobile homes à des
vacanciers est en cessation d'activité
et pour les autres c'est encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes ils sont indemnisés au
moins 50% par schiphol à partir du
moment où le fipol reconnaît le
préjudice est en ce qui concerne et 50%
complémentaires on est toujours en
attente de
mais en place concrète de promesses qui
ont été faites par le ministre
ici à saint pierre de quiberon qu'on ne
croit pas aux promesses du gouvernement
pour l'hôtel de bretagne 20 % de perte
de pâques à fin juillet est sans doute
beaucoup plus pour le reste de l'été
mais le bilan n'est pas encore connu
bien sûr on peut se tourner vers le
conseil général mais là aussi les aides
sont jugées insuffisantes et c'est très
bien les avances sur trésorerie
mais c'est sur 18 mois sur 18 mois ça
fait court sur une saison comme la nôtre
c'est pas possible ça toucher aussi les
particuliers propriétaires de logements
de vacances
isabelle mère mais qui a restauré cette
maison de pêcheur pour la louer à une
clientèle anglaise a perdu 70 mille
francs cette année
ce qui est important c'est que l'on ait
beaucoup de manques manque de clientèle
est étrangère ce qui quitteraient pas
important pour la commune et puis pour
faire tourner tous les commerces les
environs c'est vrai que c'est très
important et personne n'est optimiste
pour l'avenir parce que les vacanciers
ont découvert autre chose cette année et
vont peut être changer leurs habitudes
et parce qu'il y a vingt ans après la
moco cadix il avait fallu cinq ans pour
remonter la pente mais ce n'est qu'un au
revoir
cela veut dire beaucoup de contrôles de
meilleurs contrôles sur les bateaux sur
ces pétroliers sur ces épave flottante
qu'on voit de temps en temps croiser ici
dans l'océan et il n'y a pourtant que 54
inspecteurs en france il en faudrait au
moins le double enquête maintenant sur
la sécurité en mer et sur le travail des
inspecteurs
pour les chaînes commandants passent par
la semaine mis une descente de police ni
une visite de courtoisie
il s'agit d'une inspection des affaires
maritimes sur un pétrochimie qui est
français en escale au havre
ces trois contrôleurs vont passer le
navire au peigne fin
[Applaudissements]
contrôler les contrôles ça commence
toujours comme ça attestations
certificats
on vérifie tout jusqu'aux dates de mise
anciens vis des bouteilles incendie
navigant tous les trois
on navigue et en
5es
et vingt ans donc connais le milieu
reconnaît les problèmes des gens je
pense que les gens du dehors ça on
connaît le problème est qu'on n'est pas
là pour les ennuyer mais pour le rendre
service à ses fonctionnaires ont tout
pouvoir
c'est eux qui délivre les permis de
naviguer et qui prennent des sanctions
cas de déficience alors tatillon ils
vont tester l'ensemble du système de
sécurité sur un bateau comme celui là
qui transportent des matières
dangereuses
il faut pouvoir jeter ou lever l'ancré
rapidement surtout il faut que les
installations anti incendie soit fiable
il en va de la vie de l'équipage mais là
s'arrête leurs investigations des
entrailles du navire de l'état de la
coque
il ignore tout la structure elle a été
contrôlée avant nous par la société de
classification en l'occurrence sur ce
bateau le bureau veritas et donc nous
avons commencé lorsque nous avons
vérifié les papiers du bord que
effectivement l'attestation que ces
contrôles avaient été faits se
trouvaient bien à bord faire confiance
aux documents c'est bien là le problème
et le naufrage de l'erika l'a rappelé
ils sont effectivement peut-être qu'il y
avait une
certaine légèreté a accordé les
certificats navigation difficile de
combattre ces pratiques
sinon renforcer les contrôles de la vie
de ce capitaine la catastrophe aura au
moins servi à ça
les contre l'administration semble
de partir dans
dans le bon sens
manche que peut-être que l'erika
pousser un petit peu
la sauce enflammé
ça s'est mieux passé qui en avant
certainement et pourtant il y en a
encore des bateaux poubelles des
pavillons étrangers le plus souvent qui
échappent à la vigilance
faut dire qu'ici au havre sept
contrôleurs veille tala sécurité du port
concept mille bateaux vont et viennent
chaque année en tout et pour tout en
france 54 inspecteurs un chiffre
dérisoire que le ministre des transports
a promis de multiplier par deux et pas
avant fin 2011 le quatrième groupe
pétrolier mondial total fina elf a eu
son image écornée par cette histoire de
pollution écologique et en même temps a
fait énormément de bénéfices
le point maintenant sur la
responsabilité et les indemnisations
développé par total monsieur s'activent
dans l'atelier pendant que madame tient
la caisse
depuis dix ans ce couple gère une
station total
ils se sont installés ici dans le centre
ville de nantes
et il y a un an ils ont subi de plein
fouet la crise erika c'était difficile
parce que on était toujours citées dans
les médias on était en effet en première
ligne c'était nous qui revient
il était en face aux clients et donc ce
n'était pas toujours facile à gérer mais
je pense qu'on l'a fait au mieux et puis
le résultat est que l'on n'a pas perdu
nos clients malgré la catastrophe les
clients sont restés fidèles ils n'ont
pas répondu aux appels au boycott
ils ont même parfois apporté leur
soutien dans les moments difficiles
je pense que c'est tombé par hasard sur
le sur un bateau qui était affrété par
total sera pu être quelqu'un d'autre et
puis ils sont commerçants comme moi ils
ont leur clientèle à défendre ils sont
pour rien vous en avez parlé un peu tous
les dehors non on a eu l'occasion d'en
discuter les deux bien sûr parce que bon
c'est la touche est quand même il a
quand même
pignon sur rue à il fait partie d'un
quartier où les gens connaissent ici
comme partout en france les ventes n'ont
pas baissé
le client n'a pas déserté les stations
total cette année grâce à la conjoncture
le groupe pétrolier enregistre
d'ailleurs des résultats record 22
milliards de francs sur les six premiers
mois de l'année reste la mauvaise image
que total tente d'effacer depuis un an
avec plus ou moins de succès le défi
pour l'entreprise c'est pas de dire i
s'est rien passé et on va tout oublié
non c'est de dire je mets ça de côté et
je reviendrai un jour pour montrer
qu'aujourd'hui je peux avoir la tête
haute avec les investissements que j'ai
fait pour réparer le mal qui a été
réalisé en attendant d'avoir la tête
haute
la vie continue pour notre couple de
gérants et les affaires vont plutôt bien
ce jour là ils ont vendu tout leur gaz
oil jusqu'à la rupture de stock
le procès du naufrage de l'erika est le
premier en france d'une catastrophe
écologique majeure le tribunal
correctionnel de paris à quatre mois
pour établir les responsabilités
après sept ans d'enquêté quinze
personnes morales et physiques ont été
renvoyés devant la justice pour
pollution en décembre 99 ce bateau avait
pris la mer en pleine tempête
avec trente mille tonnes de pétrole à
son bord véronique gens alors albert
oscillé dans le kent
une centaine d'avocats quinze prévenus
70 parties civiles et pour le premier
jour du procès du naufrage de l'erika
trois candidats à l'élection
présidentielle dans les couloirs du
palais de justice
dominique voynet ministre de
l'environnement au moment de la
catastrophe mais aussi corinne lepage
avocate de plusieurs communes et
philippe de villiers ont fait entendre
leur voix avant l'audience
je suis là pour défendre un département
qui a été souillé une côte atlantique
qui a été blessé et aussi pour pour
penser à l'avenir parce que depuis que
nous nous parlons il ya déjà deux
bateaux poubelles qui sont passés sur le
rail d'ouessant
j'en attends que la justice passe et
aussi que le coût soit élevé non pas par
plaisir de faire payer mais parce que
nous vivons dans un monde économique où
seuls comptent malheureusement la
finance et il faut que polluer les
coudes ça coûte très cher sinon ça
continuera 12 décembre 99 l'erika se
casse en deux libérant 20 mille tonnes
de fuel bilan 400 km de côtes souillées
et plus de cent cinquante mille oiseaux
mazoutés
le préjudice infligé à l'économie
bretonne est évalué à plus d'un milliard
d'euros un grand absent à l'audience
aujourd'hui le capitaine indien du
navire filmé lors de son arrestation
en revanche l'ancien propriétaire un
golden boy italien giuseppe savarese
s'est présentée il est soupçonné d'avoir
violé délibérément les règles de
sécurité
quant au groupe total l'affréteur de
l'erika son système de défense n'a pas
varié depuis sept ans la compagnie
prends des navires
qui sont certifiés qui dispose de
certificats en l'espèce il les avait
tous il était fort bien cotés par
l'épaule
il venait de passer en grande visite
quinze mois plus tôt c'est quand il n'y
avait aucune raison qu'il ne soit pas
affréter le procès devra expliquer
pourquoi l'erika un bateau à une seule
coque vieux de 25 ans a pris la mer en
pleine tempête malgré plusieurs
inspections ayant signalé de grave
traces de corrosion et sans détour
corinne lepage ray pour à nos questions
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes un président du mouvement
écologiste cap21 avocate vous
représentiez les collectivités locales à
ce procès de la catastrophe de l'erika
vous êtes ancien ministre de
l'environnement pourquoi la justice
reconnaît aujourd'hui que le préjudice
et écologique dans cette catastrophe
alors que ça n'avait jamais été fait
avant on a un autre exemple en tête qui
est celui que vous connaissez bien de
l'amoco cadiz alors sur l'amo complet 10
le principe avait été admis mais on
avait considéré qu'il y avait plus de
dommages 14 ans plus tard et eu deux
petites décide de décision en france qui
avait déjà été rendu mais c'est la
première fois qu'ils à une
reconnaissance avec l'application d'un
principe aussi vaste et par exemple
indemnisation pour la lpo la ligue de
protection des oiseaux des oiseaux morts
pour les collectivités locales il ya le
principe de la réparation du préjudice
écologique et le morbihan par exemple
récupère quelques milliers d'euros à ce
titre
qu'est-ce que ça va changer ça va
changer que dans l'équation économique d
affréteurs et de toute la chaîne du
transport pétrolier on va savoir qu'une
catastrophe en europe et notamment en
france ça peut coûter très cher et qu'il
vaut mieux prendre des bateaux qui sont
ces cures plutôt que d'en prendre des
poubelles
un mot sur la condamnation de total je
dirais que pour les collectivités
locales c'est une satisfaction d'abord
psychologique parce qu'elle avait le
sentiment d'être méprisés au départ de
ce dossier et puis juridique dans la
mesure il est essentiel que tous les
acteurs de la chaîne puisse être
responsable ici vous savez ce qu'a dit
le tribunal c'est du bon sens et
d'écouté totale vous avez contrôler ce
bateau vous avez donné un feu vert vous
avez accepté de le prendre vous saviez
qu'il était mauvais état vous avez
commis une imprudence et voilà 192
millions d'euros c'est le maximum qu'ils
pouvaient être obtenues non c'est pas le
maximum puisque a pas de plafond pour la
réparation des dommages yens 1 pour les
sanctions pénales mais pas pour la
réparation des dommages c'est une somme
importante c'est moins que ce qu'on
espérait les mais combien l'évaluation
du préjudice écologique les communes
n'en ont pas eu par contre le tribunal a
été assez généreux en ce qui concerne
l'atteinte à l'image de marque puisque
par exemple les communes que je défends
ont reçu entre un million et demi et
cinq cent mille euros
les pétroliers disent que les parties
civiles réclamaient un milliard d'euros
on s'est un peu moins que ça d'abord en
plus met donc un peu plus que 180 ml oui
oui elle faute être est ce que est ce
que est ce que c'est un quand même un
demi échec ou est-ce que vous considérez
que les communes ont été indemnisées
quand même à la hauteur du préjudice
subi par non pas la totalité du
préjudice subi certainement pas parce
qu'il ya toute une partie du préjudice
toute façon qu'on n'arrive jamais à
évaluer convenablement
mais ce n'est certainement pas un échec
ou un quart des chèques en demi échec
non c'est une victoire pour les
collectivités locales et les parties
civiles
au moment où
l'on part j'allais dire des dizaines
mais peut-être moins peut-être plus je
ne sais pas de bateaux poubelles
sillonnent les mers du globe
que faire contre cela ce que vous pensez
sincèrement que ce jugement
d'aujourd'hui va être dissuasif écoutez
il va être certainement dissuasif au
moins pour les côtes européennes ce qui
s'est passé en france à moi la vie est
intéressant au niveau de l'europe et du
reste je plaide devant la cour de
justice mardi prochain sur la suite du
procès erika en ce qui concerne la
notion de déchets et donc cela intéresse
toute l'europe
vous savez les états unis ont changé
leur législation et grâce à ça bien plus
de bateaux poubelles aux états unis bien
ce qui vient de se passer avec les
ricains en france j'espère sera la même
conséquence mais c'est parce de les
grandes légendes nationales
non c'est un changement de jurisprudence
mais peut être annonciateur d'un
changement de législation sur la
responsabilité de tous les acteurs car
aujourd'hui les affréteurs continue à
n'être pas responsable
il n'est pas admissible dans la société
contemporaine que un acteur économique
puisse dire moi quoi que je fasse une si
jamais responsable c'est à pau il faut
rappeler que total n'a dans la sphère de
l'erika n'a pas été condamné en tant
qu'acteur il a été condamné parce qu'il
avait fait le contrôle de votre premier
titre donc ce soir la fin d'un des
grands procès de la décennie en matière
d'environnement celui de la marée noire
de l'erika et bien après dix ans
d'attenté total est condamné
ainsi que l'armateur et le gestionnaire
du pétrolier dominique verdeilhan
mathieu dreujou l'erika se résume
désormais à une énorme facture dix ans
après la catastrophe
la justice continue d'évaluer l'exacte
préjudice de la pollution le groupe
total est considérée comme l'affréteur
véritable de l'erika pénalement
responsable il est condamné à 375000
euros d'amande
mais surprise la cour d'appel l'exonère
de toute indemnité
le pétrolier n'a donc rien à débourser
après les 171 millions déjà versés
ça ne change pas les engagements que
nous avons pris vis-à-vis
toutes les parties civiles qui ont été
indemnisées à la suite du jugement en
première instance ces indemnisations
elles sont acquises total coupable mais
pas responsable une décision
difficilement compréhensible pour ceux
qui ont eu à pâtir de la pollution
provoquée par l'erika au niveau des
indemnisations si j'ai bien compris et à
faire quand on garde ça devrait à mon
avis il échappe pratiquement à tous
annoncent pour sa part lorsqu'un
pétrolier continuera à utiliser un
bateau poubelle il n'aura qu'un petit
risque pénal mais ça ne lui coûtera rien
et ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement préoccupant pour la suite
400 km de côtes touchées cent cinquante
mille oiseaux mazoutés la cour d'appel
alourdi les dommages et intérêts 292
millions passent à plus de 200 millions
les juges ont surtout étendu le
préjudice écologique
dix fois plus qu'en première instance on
ne pourra plus se comporter demain comme
ont levé hier la reconnaissance du
préjudice écologique est vraiment une
victoire le dossier erika n'a pas fini
sa carrière judiciaire la cour de
cassation dira l'an prochain si elle
valide la décision prise aujourd'hui
[Musique]